okay for today's classic interview we're
going back to an awesome interview I did
with Michael Mann three and a half years
ago about the real impact of climate
change and I am completely sick of this
narrative that there is a debate as to
if and when climate change is going to
become a problem for humans on the
planet it's a problem now and Michael
Mann talked to us about that back in
December of 2015 what he said then is
particularly relevant now as everything
he talked about has accelerated and
there is no more sort of when is it that
we will be able to identify the
real-world effects of climate change
they're happening now Michael Mann knows
it our audience back in 2015 knew it and
we're going to go back to that interview
today with Michael Mann Michael Mann is
distinguished professor and director of
the Earth System science Center at Penn
State University and also author of two
books including dire predictions
understanding climate change and the
hockey stick and the climate Wars it's
so great to have you on and the book
really presents in sort of ordinary
straightforward language the important
findings of what is currently happening
with the the climate crisis on earth I
would love to start at the broadest
point possible with regard to what
predictions we can make and predictions
people may have heard about the future
of the climate crisis people sometimes
euro the entire East Coast will be
underwater or all of the ice will be
melted and the polar ice caps etc and
sometimes it sounds a little bit
hyperbolic so let's break it down what
are the real concerns with regards to
what we can predict will happen as a
result of continued climate change
Thanks it's good to be on the show with
you so if we continue with business as
usual burning of fossil fuels if we
don't take precautionary actions to deal
with our increased ongoing emissions of
carbon into the atmosphere we will
likely see between 7 & 9 degrees
fahrenheit warming of the globe by the
end of the century now that won't you
know it
that doesn't mean that the the entire us
will be submerged below the ocean it
means that there will likely be enough
sea level rise to force us essentially
to retreat from many of the major
coastal cities of the US and elsewhere
around the world
it will mean that many of the problems
we are already seeing damaging impacts
of climate change-related increases in
extreme weather wildfires droughts
flooding all those things that we have
seen already worsened weather events
because of the impact of climate change
will get that much worse if we again
continue with business as usual burning
of fossil fuels by the end of the
century we warm the plant by seven to
nine degrees Fahrenheit arguably the
rates of change that we will see in our
climate will exceed our ability to adapt
to those changes
I'm curious Michael as far as the
temperature change you know we talked
about the sea level rise that we would
see what the if if our oceans were
warmer also would that not have a
significant impact on ocean life and
thus the entire animal ecosystem yeah
that's right in fact right now we have a
major El Nino event going on and it sort
of gives us a glimpse of the future
because during El Ninos often sea
surface temperatures or around the the
world are much warmer than they would
normally be and with those large El Nino
events like the one we're seeing right
now we often see a massive die-off of
corals we see an event called coral
bleaching where our corals they lose
their color because the symbiotic
organisms that give them that color
literally literally flee but the corals
can't move they're stuck and if that
goes on long enough that kills off the
corals that is combined with the effects
of ocean acidification as we increase
the o2 in the atmosphere the oceans
become more acidic so all of these
things are impacting ocean biota coral
reefs
this is part
the reason that climate change
represents a major threat to ocean
biodiversity to fish populations and our
ability to continue to feed ourselves
through fishing I would love to hear a
little bit from you about how our
audience can tackle when they are on the
receiving end of what to me sounds like
a tired old talking point from so called
climate sceptics or non non science
believers as I like to call them that
hey listen humans on earth we only have
observations about temperature from a
very tiny slice of the history of our
planet and there's really no way at all
to say that the the changes in
temperature we're seeing today are any
more than just cyclical temperature
changes we've had ice ages and it
logically follows we also have warmer
periods we only have a little bit of
data that's a very common talking point
we hear from climate sceptics what can
our audience have sort of in their
arsenal to refute that sure so I will
respond to that particular talking point
but it's often very useful to draw upon
resources that exist out there there is
a site called skeptical science calm and
if you go to that website they have a
list of the hundred or so leading
climate change denier talking points and
the scientific responses to each of
those talking points at the introductory
intermediate and advanced level that's
uh and even better than that you can
download the whole thing onto your
smartphone and have it at your
fingertips so you know what that
Thanksgiving dinner where that
cantankerous uncle that you have your
items aren't with you know you've got
that at your disposal and you can
respond to them in real time but with
that particular talking point it's
actually combining a number of myths
first of all it wouldn't even matter if
the current warmth that we've seen
whether or not it's unprecedented the
reason for past periods of warmth is
understood the reason that you know the
temperatures were so warm during the
early cretaceous period when dinosaurs
roamed the planet that was because of
very high co2 levels a very
greenhouse effect and that happened
naturally over tens of millions of years
due to natural variations in the
concentrations of these greenhouse gases
that have to do with things like plate
tectonics so those changes happen over a
timescale of you know it's a hundred
million years if you go back to the
early cretaceous period what we are
doing by burning fossil fuels is
literally taking all the carbon that got
buried in the ground after that period
over a hundred million years and we're
putting it back up into the atmosphere
but over a time scale of a hundred years
a million times faster so it's the rate
at which we are modifying the atmosphere
and warming the planet that is cause for
concern not whether or not there might
have been past periods periods in the
distant past there that were as warm one
other thing we do know that the recent
warming spike is unprecedented going
back into the last ice age and probably
back more than a hundred thousand years
there are various lines of paleo climate
evidence that we can use to piece
together the puzzle of how the climate
changed in the past and those data tell
us that the recent warming spike is
likely unprecedented in tens of
thousands of years maybe more than a
hundred thousand years so it is unusual
and the co2 concentrations that we've
reached already are higher than they've
been in millions of years we know that
as well and Michael how drastic do human
activities on earth have to change to
really make a dent in the impact that
we're having you know sometimes I'll
read about a new initiative for example
we could move 30% of New York State's
electricity consumption to renewable and
and green alternative energies on a per
capita basis and I'm thinking per capita
our population continues to increase
we're talking only about 30% it seems
like ten years from now any benefit that
we get from doing that is already going
to be undone by our population growth um
is my sort of pessimism or feeling
overwhelmed by the the magnitude of what
we have on our hands here justified or
can we really make a dent in this yeah I
think it's a little overly pessimistic
a population in the US isn't climbing
its population in developing nations
that continues to climb but when
demographers look at sort of the
large-scale trends right now with global
population they estimate that will
probably plateau by the middle of this
century at about nine million people so
yes there will be more people right now
there are about seven billion people but
that's not going to continue on an
exponential trajectory like it has in
the past it appears to be plateauing out
now can we provide energy for those
people without the continued burning of
fossil fuels that's the real challenge
and you know you mentioned you know the
possibility of New York generating 30
percent of its electricity from
renewables well Germany is already doing
it Germany is doing that the if you look
around the globe if you tally the total
global electricity use we are now up to
about 22 percent of our electricity
generation globally and coming from
renewables so there has been a dramatic
turning of the corner just over the past
few years in moving away from burning of
fossil fuels moving towards renewable
energy to generate electricity we've got
a lot farther to go but last year for
the first time ever for the first time
in many decades we saw global economic
growth without any growth in carbon
emissions right I mean there's a hard on
that that expensive way that that seems
to be a really important indicator of
where things could go with the right
decisions made is it not absolutely it
suggests that we're turning the corner
now we're not yet turning the corner
fast enough to stabilize those
greenhouse gas concentrations below
dangerous levels so it's going to take a
lot more work but there's reason for
cautious optimism we are already
beginning to turn the corner well any
conversation about climate change where
my view is unnecessarily pessimistic for
me is a win you know I mean that's
that's good news for sure
I'll remind our audience we've been
speaking with Michael Mann distinguished
professor and director of the Earth
System science Center at Penn State
University check out his book dire
predictions understand
climate change thanks so much for
joining me today thank you it was a
pleasure talking with you